Traits come in two main types, quantitative
or qualitative. Quantitative traits vary continuously over a
range of measurements, and display in statistics what
we call a normal distribution or bell curve.
We've already talked about one of these breast
cancer risk. Good examples of this are. Things
like height or weight. You can see that
measurements for height vary continuously over a range.
And that we have an average height. But
there is a spectrum for all other possible
heights. Everybody has these traits. But they vary
in their quantities on a continuous spectrum. You could
be five feet tall. You could be six
feet tall. Anywhere in between. Now, qualitative traits don't
have this quantitative aspect. Instead, qualitative traits are
said to vary discontinuously. They measure the presence or
absence of something, maybe a category that something falls
into. For example, you may be right or left
handed or you may be ambidextrous which is a
mix of both. But we typically don't quantify a
trait like this. You're either right handed or you're
not. Now some of you more advanced learners out
there may take issue with this, sort of, simple
categorization here. But this is very useful in research.
Being able to categorize traits as quantitative
or qualitative and then measure them accordingly. Allows
us to plan and carry out research that
can correlate with various outcomes. So let's look
at the polygenic trait of eye color,
poylgenic, remember, meaning that it's influenced by multiple
genes. Suppose we classify everyone based on whether
they have. Brown eye color, green eye color,
blue eye color. Would this be an example of a quantitative or qualitative trait?